on Monday night it looked like the
Seahawks as Chris Sims would say crack
the code on the Seattle offense and it's
quite possible that they did Bobby
Wagner Seahawks middle linebacker said
via NFL media they're a team that runs
so many different things that it's hard
to get a tendency but I felt like the
last couple of times that we played them
we were able to figure out what they
were doing because they run so many
different things it's a game where you
have to be disciplined you have to read
your plays it becomes kind of like
simple football read your keys and it
will take you to the football once we
started reading Keys and KJ rights
started hearing the calls and picked up
on the checks Jimmy Garoppolo was making
it allowed us to break faster Chris how
common is this and how troubling is this
if it's happening to an offense well
it's common especially it gets division
opponents you know this is what is this
the fifth time that Bobby Wagner's got
to see the Kyle Shanahan offense right
in three years so it does happen I mean
the first thing we need to talk about is
what the hell are you doing telling
everybody that why for later in the year
when we're playing for the NFC West
title I mean come on man I mean I just
can't I don't know what to say about
that that was truly a bonehead move by
him there but it does go on and it's
especially division robberies now I
don't think he's I think what he's
really specifically talking to is he
could probably hear some of the words
Garoppolo saying some of the words the
linemen are saying at the line of
scrimmage when they're making their
calls as far as how they want to block
certain things and yes it gave Bobby
Wagner a beat I know my dad he'll tell
you the story but about you know those
great Eagles defenses in the in the late
80s early 90s where yeah my dad was
playing him twice a year he started to
figure out some of their checks and he
would make plays against them and he has
told me the story and even told the
story on my podcast where you know then
the Eagles players like how did you
throw the ball there how did you know
that even his own coaches would go you
know that's a great play Phil what made
you throw the ball over there and oh you
know coach I just saw this and he'd met
but he had he had a
understanding applying them so many
times that when he heard Seth Joyner
across the line of scrimmage you know
say some word he went oh I know that
coverage or I know that blitz I've heard
it before and it smacked me in the face
I had it personally happened with me
with the Carolina Panthers and I think
I've told you this story before to where
we played the Carolina Panthers in 2005
and there was a few plays they were all
over some of our stuff especially when I
audibled and checked well I went home
and watched you know inside the NFL a
few days later and you know how they
have some of the sideline stuff and guys
I realized that brenson Buckner and them
they did know some of our checks and I
told Jon Gruden so then the next time we
played them we used those checks but
they meant different things and they
thought they were gonna mean the same
thing and we kind of burned them with it
so this is part of the gamesmanship of
the NFL but I just don't understand
where Bobby Wagner would tell it and say
it publicly well and that's now what
Kyle Shanahan can start doing in an
operation for week 17 right you set them
up with a rope-a-dope you make them
think that what they're hearing means
one thing you get them moving in that
direction and then you you pull the old
switcheroo and it goes the other way so
I hadn't thought of it that way and I
yeah way when once you know what a team
is doing the most important thing to do
is keep it to yourself because you will
be playing them again possibly two more
times this year because they could end
up crossing paths in the postseason so
very important point when you know
something like that don't give in to the
human temptation to share with others
things that you know no and let me tell
you that is a defect in our genetic
composition as human beings when we know
something that somebody else doesn't
know we feel yeah oh I can't wait to
tell you can't wait I guess hey I know
this you're right you're exactly right
that's what goes on this is part you
know again too it's not like Garoppolo
or Shanahan's fault or anything like
that but you do as an NFL quarterback
and offensive coordinator and a lot of
teams don't change their offensive line
calls up front
very often but the 49ers are probably
not to go to the drawing board and
change that language just a little bit
but this is where when your same system
same coach division rivals playing them
twice a year you have to stay on top of
your signals and stuff you say at the
line of scrimmage and make sure you
continue to change them and not say
things because teams that are really
smart will find through the TV copy and
through the film and oh I heard him say
this on the TV copy and then they ran
this route they'll start to put things
together and you do have to make sure
you continue to change those things up
to keep a team you know on edge and not
and not be all over some of your checks
and things like that did you have any
habits that you had to stop doing
because it was giving away cuz every
time I see a guy like lick his fingers a
quarterback lick his fingers before a
play I'm thinking always that some sort
of a tell does he do it every play does
he only do it when he passes I mean did
you have anything like that that was it
that they ultimately spotted on film I I
don't know if I did I was very conscious
of that though the licking of the hands
and sometimes I would wet my towel that
was in front of me like if it was a dry
cool day right and you know I just got
sick of licking my hands I would wet the
towel to give my hands just a little
moisture as I'm like getting ready and I
did realize a few times that I'm passing
plays I was certainly grabbing it more
than I was on running plays and I had to
make a mental note and practice during
the week you know what I got to grab it
every play I can't just do it on the
passing plays and that was one that
certainly jumped out to me that happened
a few times in my career
[Music]
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports